hello Lavon thank you so much for
joining me here today how do you feel
about being back in San Luis and playing
in this chess
chess or chest nine elex event well yeah
I'm back home so it's always very
enjoyable to be around my friends and
uh to see
everybody at the club
Rex and you know all the all the great
players is this your favorite chess
variant chess 960. absolutely yeah so
there's no question about it
there's so much variety it's such a
beautiful game how do you prepare for
chess uh 1960 do you prepare in any way
differently than
um classical chess or is there something
different that you do in general for
these types of events
well since there are no openings
what do you need to do is actually
uh do lots of tactics before the
tournaments because the game is very
tactical you know in order to get the
strategical position that you desire you
need to really calculate a lot so that's
the difference Bobby Fisher is
mentioning how important spatial
perception was for chess what do you
think is the most important in chess 960
I think is
uh the more I mean chest 960 has this
special uh feel about it that you really
need to understand where the pieces are
going so it's more about planning and
also very much about space you know and
you know you always have to come up with
uh some some some sort of uh alternative
way of developing because quite often
you know you can't develop just
naturally you know you you have to
compromise some things so it's
brilliant game what can I say it is
really nice for the for this particular
tournament you have 20 minutes plus 10
seconds increment and you find out the
position you're going to be playing 15
minutes before you actually have to sit
down at the board and play
is that do you think that's sufficient
time and how important it is to how do
you use it the best way
well uh you know I think
chest 960 still is not as popular as it
deserves to be
and you know I can't wait for a
classical time control to be applied
such as 960 you know and ratings to be
calculated and for the game to be taken
seriously because it's the it's clearly
is the future of the chess for me
so classical chess 960 sounds good is
that your favorite type of Chess
classical chess or
um I I love all kinds of time formats
but I just think for a game as complex
as Chesney 60 you definitely need a lot
of time to think so
20 plus 5 is a lot of fun but I would
consider it a blitz or
Wireless and Blitz it's very nice I was
going to ask you that you recently
become a dad how do you how has your
life changed and how are you able to
manage raising your daughter and
continue becoming strong professional
chess player
well I think becoming father is
something that motivates you you know
that
to be a better person it
a more successful person in your life
that's uh
you know it kind of of course takes a
lot of effort but also gives you the
energy and gives you
I think the ultimate Joy this tournament
has probably it's amazing strong field
um of course Gary casparo is taking part
in the tournament too
who is is he the one that you're looking
most forward to playing against or is
there someone else you're looking fast
forward to
I love playing against everybody you
know and uh
we analyze
the chestnut CC with Fabi so
and he does come up with very good ideas
so of course
I look forward to playing against him
you know just too
get challenged
you see well thank you so much for
joining me today I wish you good luck
I'm looking forward to seeing your
competing in the tournament thank you
thank you